HOW IS THAT?
>> GARY COHN HOPEFULLY WILL BE
STAYED FOR A LONG TIME.
THAT WAS IN CAMP DAVID 2 MONTHS
AGO.
GARY COHN IS LEAVING THE WHITE
HOUSE IN ABOUT 3 WEEKS TIME.
PUT OUT A STATEMENT AND HERE'S
PART WHAT HAVE IS READ:
>> WE HAVE A STATEMENT FROM THE
PRESIDENT AS WELL THAT READS:
ALL OF THAT NEWSBREAKING ONE
HOUR AGAIN.
MICHAEL NEEDHAM IN HERITAGE
ACTION FOR AMERICA.
ANDY
AND
ANDY WALTER AND ELI LAKE.
WE HAD A DIFFERENT TOPIC
PREPARED BUT THIS IS THE TOPIC
OF THE HOUR.
MICHAEL?
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
IT'S BEEN TALKED ABOUT AS
HAPPENING FOR MANY, MANY MONTHS.
IT WAS STILL SURPRISING WHEN IT
HAPPENED.
GARY COHN HAS BEEN PART OF A
FANTASTIC TEAM AND TREMENDOUS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS LIKE THE TAX
CUTS.
AND ROLLING BACK DOWD FRANK.
GARY COHN HAS BEEN THERE AT THE
PRESIDENT'S SIDE WITH A
REMARKABLE RECORD.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE PRESIDENT
NOT TO ROLL THAT BACK WITH
TARRIFS OR OTHER POLICIES IN
RECENT DAYS.
>> I BELIEVE THEY HAD A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP.
HE DREW THE LINE ON TARRIFS.
>> YES, HE DREW THE LINE ON A
NUMBER OF THINGS.
HE WAS UPSET ABOUT THE PULLING
OUT OF PARIS ACCORD.
HE WAS NOT A BIG FAN OF THAT.
THEN THERE WAS A DRAMATIC BREAK
WITH THE PRESIDENT ON THE
PRESIDENT'S REACTION TO THE
VIOLENCE IN CHARLOTTESVILLE WITH
COHN SAYING, I WAS THINKING
ABOUT RESIGNING AND PENNED A
LETTER OF RESIGNATION BUT WILL
STICK WITH THIS ADMINISTRATION.
BUT I DISAGREE WITH THE
PRESIDENT SAYING THERE WAS
VIOLENCE ON BOTH SIDES.
THE TARRIFS ISSUES DIVIDED THE
PRESIDENT'S ECONOMIC TEAM.
HE WAS ARGUING AGAINST MORE
TARRIFS OR ANY TARRIFS AT ALL.
THAT'S NOT PARTICULARLY
SURPRISING TO SEE THAT HE IS ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF IT.
I AGREE THAT IT'S SURPRISING IT
WAS TODAY.
BUT I THINK WE ALL KNEW WHOEVER
WON THE WAR ON TARRIFS WAS GOING
TO STAY IN AND WHO LOST WOULD
LEAVE.
>> IT APPEARED THAT GARY COHN
CAME FROM THE LEFT SIDE OF THE
AISLE WHEN IT CAME TO POLITICS.
GARY COHN IS SIDING WITH
REPUBLICANS ON THE HILL WITH THE
TARRIFS ISSUE.
THAT'S DRIVING A WEDGE BETWEEN
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS AND THE
PRESIDENT WHO SAID I RAN ON
THIS.
>> THE PRESIDENT RAN ON A LOT OF
THINGS HE DIDN'T DO.
IT DOESN'T MEAN IT'S A GOOD
THING TO EMBRACE AN ECONOMIC
POLICY FROM 100 YEARS AGO.
I THINK IT'S BAD FOR THE
CONSTITUENCY.
A LOT OF PRICES WILL GO UP.
GARY COHN COMES FROM GOLDMAN
SACHS.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT BOTH LEFT
AND RIGHT AND NEITHER LEFT OR
RIGHT.
IT REPRESENTS THE CENTER OF
AMERICAN POLITICS.
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT BLOW.
I THINK IT SHOWS A FRACTURE OF
AMERICAN POLITIC IN A DEEP WAY.
THE FACT THAT SO MANY
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS AND A
LOT OF DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS ARE
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE TARRIFS
POLICY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS A LOT OF
AUTHORITY HERE.
>> THE WEST WINGITSELF, OVER THE
LAST 13.5 MONTHS, ON-SCREEN WE
WILL PUT THE NUMBERS AND FACES
WHO WERE IN THE WEST WINGARE
GONE.
I COUNT 19 IN LESS THAN 14
MONTHS.
THIS TWEET FROM THE PRESIDENT ON
WHITE HOUSE CHAOS IS INTERESTING
TOO:
>> MICHAEL?
>> WELL, IT FEELS CHAOTIC TODAY.
IF YOU LOOK OVER THE LAST 14
MONTHS, IT'S BEEN A WHITE HOUSE
THAT HAS STORMED AND COME
TOGETHER AND COME TOGETHER.
IT WORKS BETTER WHEN THE TEAM IS
WORKING TOGETHER.
WASHINGTON NEEDS STRONG
EXECUTIVE LEADERSHIP.
CONGRESS 535 PEOPLE WITH
DIFFERENT AMBITTIONS NEED AN
EXECUTIVE BRANCH THAT SAYS LET'S
GO FORWARD.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS IN THE PAST.
I AM SURE THE WHITE HOUSE WILL
COME BACK TOGETHER AND OPERATE
IN A MORE NORMAL FASHION.
>> HE SAID IF PEOPLE LEAVE, I
HAVE PLENTY OF PEOPLE TO COME
RIGHT THROUGH THE DOOR.
HE SAID WE HAVE HAD PLENTY OF
TALENTED PEOPLE WHO WANT TO WORK
HERE AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> WELL, WE WILL SEE WHO TAKES
THE PLACE OF THE NATIONAL
ECONOMIC ADVISOR.
LOOK, THE CHAOS IS PART OF THE
STRATEGY.
IT'S NOT A BUG IN THE SYSTEM.
IT IS THE SYSTEM.
THIS IS WHERE THE PRESIDENT
FEELS THE MOST COMFORTABLE,
BEING IN A SITUATION WHERE IT
LOOKS AS IF THERE IS NO ORDER
AND HE SEEMS TO BE THE MOST
COMFORTABLE IN THAT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE, THAT'S NOT HOW
THEY LIKE TO WORK.
IT IS ALSO A VERY DIFFICULT WAY
TO PUSH STRATEGY.
ALL REPUBLICANS ON THE HILL WANT
TO TALK ABOUT RIGHT NOW:
TAX CUTS AND THE ECONOMY,
PERIOD.
THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
TARRIFS OR GO OFF ON TANGENTS
THAT THE PRESIDENT AND THE WHITE
HOUSE SEEM TO BE UNABLE TO FOCUS
JUST ON THAT ONE STRATEGY.
>> CHAOS IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
IT'S NOT COMPARABLE TO ANY
MODERN PRESIDENT.
I THINK THE NUMBER OF
RESIGNATIONS, THE FACT IT'S HARD